the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com thank you
for tuning in here thank you for
listening watching
if you're watching hit that damn
subscribe button don't just watch
subscribe to the do
it helps the show it's free subscribe
all right we've got time
codes below all the episodes so if you
wanted to jump to a story or share
something you can go right to that
um and the patreon i can't thank you
enough for your
support out there if you guys haven't
subscribed
you're missing on out on a shitload of
[ __ ] crazy stories out there these
stories
are wild you guys are fantastic
um if you or someone you know has a
story has to be heard please submit at
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com we're going through them we'll
get to you eventually i'm sure i'd love
to do an episode with all of you we're
not stopping anytime soon
um it's five bucks a month there's only
one tier that's it it's five bucks
there's no t-shirts and this and that
club membership and
zoom hellos it's five [ __ ] bucks you
get an episode a week
um and i do know that sixty dollars a
year right now i say it every week it is
a lot of money for some people it's a
utility bill it's diapers it's whatever
and a lot of you are unemployment so i
get it
but if you do have the means and you do
want to join us
i'd be happy to help you out by telling
you that if you sign up for a year
you'll get over a month plus of free
episodes so it does save you money if
you do that all right
uh facebook fan page please go follow me
on there
and the honeydewpodcast.com is the
website for all the merch
nights night almost a night's pants
nation like we got a bunch of nights
outside
night pants nation thank you thank you
thank you
you guys it's cold now get those comfy
night pants get those night pant nation
sweats
get them they're champion sweats not
some shitty cheaps upstate merch
is legit their stuff is quality it fits
great
we got champion night pants nation
sweats ryan sickler t-shirts hoodies all
that stuff
uh go check it out get something for
yourself get something for anybody you
love
uh and if you live in l.a and you need
any musical instruments or lessons for
your kids you can come here where i
recorded santa monica music center
and if you live anywhere in the world
you can take online classes from local
los angeles musicians
go to santa monica music dot com use the
code honeydew they'll waive the
registration fee
and they will give you one free lesson
when you sign up for a package now
that's all the important stuff out of
the way
let's get to some more important stuff
here if you're new to the show welcome
thank you for being here hit that
subscribe button on youtube and
uh if you don't know what we do we
highlight the low lights here we're over
here shining
a little bit of light on the darkness
laughing in the face of adversity these
are the stories behind the storytellers
and it's a pleasure to have this
storyteller back on the honeydew
for the second time y'all please welcome
jeremiah watkins everybody
welcome back to the honeydew hey how's
everybody doing good to be here
uh thank you for being back it's good to
be here man
thank you i'm so excited i saw you
outside and it was like
man it is so good to see friends in
person you look good you're
you're keeping it together man i'm
trying i'm doing my best well you got a
lot going on we're going to talk about
here you're about to be a new dad
yes um which is i know daunting
especially i can't imagine having a baby
during a [ __ ] global pandemic but god
bless you for it figured it is the right
time
it's perfect it's perfect the world's
going to [ __ ] let's bring another soul
into it yeah
yeah yeah some good ones um some good
ones yeah some uplifters
but also if you haven't um seen
jeremiah's first episode go back check
that out you actually came on talked
about
uh skin cancer i did yeah um get your
moles checked
yeah yeah yeah yes for real like no joke
about that
yeah i had no idea how serious skin
cancer was and it always works that way
because we're in a simulation
where you come on and you talk about um
skin cancer and then all of a sudden
here come all these stories and i see
all these articles and everything comes
flooding in and i'm like man
this [ __ ] so i even had a mole i went
and got checked good i was like what do
you think about this doctor's like yeah
it does look a little weird let's check
it out it's all good
had sunglasses on everybody's starting
to get a little big it was weird
it was cool like what wearing them hey
man
um so yeah check out his first episode
and
uh before we get into uh a bunch of new
stuff
why don't you go ahead and tell us
everything you want to promote
sure you got a new special comments
let's talk about it yeah i have a new
special that is out
right now on amazon prime that you can
check it out you can rent it on there
video on demand
apple tv roku google play all that stuff
um and if you're more of an audio person
i've got a hard copy or it's streaming
on all platforms spotify itunes i got a
great podcast that ryan has been on a
couple of times
this is for you by the way oh this is my
cause your copy bro jeremiah watkins
family reunion right here
yes sir jeremiah watkins family reunion
who's that lady on the back right there
that is
my sweet mom oh that's nice to you yeah
yeah i brought her up on stage
see i like doing things like that i uh
my first tv appearance was um
i wore my dad's pant am work shirt on it
yeah yeah just i wanted him
to be a part of it yeah they've done so
much yeah
yeah and oh this is mine yes that's all
you people keep that right here
and then uh you've been on my podcast
jeremiah wonders a couple times one of
my
it's absolutely one of my most favorite
shows to go on it's so much goddamn fun
to sit there
yeah it's just a fun riff fest it's just
being silly and acting out
characters everyone that does it i'm
they're like i'm like whose podcast
you're doing today like oh jeremy i'm
like goddamn it's so much fun like i had
such a good time i had such a good time
yeah yeah so thank you for that yeah of
course and then uh at jeremiah stand up
on social media
and uh jeremiahwatkins.com for tour
dates and all that stuff and if you want
to follow me i'm a fun follower i post a
lot so
yeah you do i'm around you're around
yeah so going back to
briefly your first episode here your
upbringing was very religious
very much so it was a catholic or
christian it was protestant christian
protestant group
yeah so like what you'd attribute to may
be like
a little bit more strict than baptist
like for most people who
or like a non-denominational kind of
thing a little bit more strict than that
it's called church of god holiness
okay and everyone in the family is a
part of this
yes okay yeah you're so you had a strict
upbringing then very much so went to
church
three times a week damn yeah
and no wonder you like to act out and
cut up like how hard was it for you
because that shit's in your
i believe it's in your dna the moment
you are conceived so
oh yeah it's not just later you all of a
sudden become this 20 year old kid that
looks back and laughs at that you're
[ __ ] off
like i can tell you and i'll bet you a
lot of you out there have been like this
some of the hardest times i've ever
laughed was trying not to laugh when
you're in church
oh bro and you see the person next to
you shaking you're just out of the core
of your eye and it's
[ __ ] killing you it is killing you
and you
can't [ __ ] yourself yeah
so i don't know how you ever got there
did you did you ever uh fall asleep on
fat lady's arms in church
no no we weren't allowed to man we had a
nun in the family you couldn't you had
to be
old you had to go to confession if you
wanted communion like it wasn't just
oh yeah we're because we'd be tired of
sitting there i would get up
all the time how long are the masses
i mean they last uh the sermons are i
mean they go
from like an hour to two hours so no it
depends
it really depends well i i'd say that
because even though you had a strip
strict upbringing you sent me some
stories you wanted to talk about because
it seems like your parents
may have been a little doing their own
thing kind of well
this was later on okay this was like
this was that's when the divorce
happened
they they threw everything out the
window oh really yeah yeah yeah so when
they split they also let god go to
all three of them yeah yeah they
divorced god too
we'll see you on the other side jesus
what happened uh basically they started
having marital problems
and uh they i think that they wanted to
start
living different versions of their lives
i think that like you just said like
when you're supposed to behave
it becomes really hard after a while and
tension builds over and over
and when you're being like that a pepper
grinder right there yeah
give me some hot pepper on my sin
oh this sins a little you get a little
bland
anytime who if one or the other
got the other mom or dad into this
religion or is that how they met
my dad definitely brought my mom over
okay you know what i mean like she i
think she went to church a little bit as
a kid i think she might have gone
to like a few i think she might have
been even catholic
as like a little girl if i remember
correctly she was like
bring your mom your mom's darth vader
she's coming over to the dark side
and then going back to the right jetta
standing there with obi-wan and her
little silhouette
yeah yeah yeah exactly all right all
right so so your dad brings mom over and
they listen
my dad's a missionary's kid so after a
while when
when you're like i was saying when
you're living one way a certain way and
you may have been
i don't think my mom was ever forced
into it i think that it was
like something where i don't know it
could have been
because she loved my dad and she wanted
to to check out what
he loved you know and what he was all
about and then she
grew accustomed to it and then started
liking it but she was always the one
that i would go up to or i'm like can we
push back on this like she was kind of
the liaison
between me and my dad on like when i
would want to do something that would
like maybe like buy a
rap cd or something like that like i'd
have to hey can i can we talk like that
and she's like
pick your battles with you know with
your dad
so uh after they started having marital
problems i think that they both kind of
had a little bit of mid-life crisis like
you know like they kind of were
reevaluating everything what did your
dad do
how old were you when they split i was
17.
oh okay you're older i was okay yeah i
was older but you saw the marital
problems yeah
yeah you see it for like it happened
like a few years a few years
building up to like uh we're getting
divorced it's like
really we know like it's happening but
from jesus you're like yes
summer vacation uh so they just
so i'd never seen my parents drink i'd
never seen them do drugs or anything
like that and i basically
they would start seeing them come home
like with a friend and it was always
like
hidden to me kind of like between them
like i i was for a while i was like
mom mom's in a good mood tonight or
something you know what i mean
it didn't really register to me until i
looked back on i was like oh
she had a little bit of that sins house
you know what i mean
yeah so uh after a while you know they
both
kind of started having their issues with
it and stuff like that and i
started seeing them drink a little bit i
don't know if i mentioned last time but
i've like
later on like my mom would start like
smoking weed with my sister and stuff
like that really
like openly yeah and i even saw them
like on shrooms together one time
how old was your sister she's a couple
years younger than me okay
yeah yeah so they so
they like started embracing so my
brother and sister like they're like
this is great you know they saw it as
like
an opportunity like oh then i can do
that too and i'm like but what about all
the years that we
we're told not to do that and i just
ended up going the other way and just
sticking like no this is what i know
because you're clean and
you you don't i've never drink before
you don't even drink no yeah you don't
smoke weed
which also is like the courage you find
without
any kind of liquid or substance is
pretty goddamn impressive
it is yeah that's the lord india i guess
well there's also jerking off in food am
i right people
there's other there's other devices
there's other
there's other stuff out there
well i won't walk around being like i'm
uh you know
um no i know all these i don't drink
people that that they have
yeah but you've got bodies in the clouds
yeah they're free yeah you're
yes exactly yeah uh so basically
they started having issues with it where
they
both had duis at some point and
they basically were
then they are they're functioning
alcoholics so separated
they both become alcoholics separately
but it was
something that was dormant i mean like
they just didn't drink in front of us
for i mean for like probably 14 years
even at a restaurant you never saw
something no my dad drank oh duels in
front of us for years
alcohol free beer and uh he would always
let my sister try it which my sister
loves beer now i'm like why would you
like she's like
it's gonna go one way or the other yeah
yeah i tasted it like this alcohol from
b i was like this is
nasty um so they
both started having drinking issues uh
where they
both got duis at different times and
they would still show up to work every
day they would never they do
work uh well my mom still works at her
job so
oh okay let's keep her employed yeah
keep her employed
um my dad has sold everything under the
sun
he's literally i mean ac
fences cars phone stuff
like he sold everything so
basically they would sometimes drink a
little bit too much
and then they got their duis
and there's a breathalyzer that's
attached to the car
and they would have trouble blowing into
it because
it would go off and it locks up the car
you only get three chances
and then you're locked out and then you
have to call a service it costs a lot of
money for them
it's a permanent lock like you're not
getting that [ __ ] undone no
no because it's like oh no you're drunk
you're you're locked out
you're done that's how this one was uh
so basically they would still want to go
to work and get to work on time
so i remember i'd be dead asleep in the
middle of the night and then i'd just
hear my mom
come into my room [ __ ] bobby bobby come
blow
you're like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you gotta blow in my car
you got you gotta get it started so i
would go up there
jumper cables or something like that but
it's different yeah okay
so i'd go up and i i would have to blow
in it because i was obviously
i was the only sounds like the only song
the only sober one i can't even go to
your sister or brother because they've
been drinking with her
there's no one else i could ask bubby
you're my last resort bubby come on i
need i need that clean breath of yours
oh my god so uh and for people who have
never blown into a breathalyzer before
uh it does take
a little bit of skill it's not just it's
it's
you have to make like a noise like it's
like
oh really yeah you have to really you're
just not exhaling hard no
you're going [ __ ] didgeridoo bruh
using that a lot hey man that's my go-to
right now i need you to work on some
space work pipe
i'll get some new space over here i do a
lot of blow jobs lay with these pepper
shakers you know what i'm saying
it is pretty it's a pretty it comes in
handy no pun intended for a lot of
different [ __ ] it does it does
uh so i was i do that for your dad also
my dad taught me more the technique of
how to blow
he's like this is this is you're taught
him how to do it accurately
yeah yeah exactly and then he's like
he's like he's like what helps me is
like when i
sing something patriotic like amazing
grace or something
oh god oh by the way i love you a lot
because
i never talk about this stuff i know you
don't i this you didn't even come on you
didn't even talk about your cancer last
time i don't think did you
i brought it up yeah yeah no i mean
prior to the show oh no that was the
first time i brought it up on your show
i brought up the whole episode yeah i
was like i was like i brought it up
for an hour yeah we talked about it
i think we covered it a little bit new
stuff
no i do appreciate you talking about
this yeah your mom and dad might not but
we do here
yeah we'll see yeah so you would do that
how many times do you remember doing
that
i mean a bunch of a bunch of times
because my mom worked early in the
morning
so and so wait she would start the car
at midnight and then let's leave it run
until like
five no driving should be at work super
early in the morning
uh like early morning shifts so they're
sensitive you have just one or two
drinks sometimes before it'll set that
thing off where it's like nope
you can't drive because you're not
supposed to be drinking at all when
you're so dui
if i go out at 1am blowing and it's like
nah you say i get two more tries so i
could wait until the next morning and
try again
yeah for sure okay all right but it's
like three attempts i think it's three
attempts like in a row
like boom boom boom yeah yeah it's kind
of like how you get locked out like on
your phone like a password or something
like that i
that's kind of how i remember it i could
be remembering wrong but yeah that we
should have that on our phones too
people should not be
on your phone [ __ ] in their phones
before they can text me you can't use it
yeah yeah you can't text
what are you doing yeah trust me don't
send that text yeah
okay so your parents basically go
unhinged a bit how old are they at this
time in their 40s 30s
uh it would have been
so my mom was if i was
14 at the time let's see this is a major
math that's happening right now
she would have been uh like there my mom
would have been in her 40s and my dad
would have been
in his 50s okay they're 10 years apart
okay
so yeah they start like having
a renaissance of activity in in their
life
like i i'd never seen my parents drunk
before until i was a teenager
so that was like shocking for me knowing
one way of life and then completely
being like oh actually what you know all
that time that we spent like telling you
like don't do that and you're going to
hell if you're doing that it's like
yeah we doing that now i'm not blowing
this problem i'm blowing this rope i'm
on my way
i'm almost the yeah yeah
man okay so when does uh are they still
drinking
uh you say they're functioning
alcoholics yeah my mom
is still drinking and then my dad uh is
still drinking he goes
like they they both like done like uh
the groups and stuff at different times
but they i think that they're both
like it does it's not as out of hand as
it used to be there it's more under
control
you know what i mean yeah there's years
where it was like like real
like they just it's clear like in my
family
just in our genetics like we have that
alcoholic gene
like running through our family like
don't have a proper
growth is that also what's part of the
reason you don't are you worried you'll
become an alcoholic if you do
um i think so i mean i i think it's one
of those things where i
i'm an addict to things that i really
like
you know what i mean like and i go a
thousand percent full steam ahead
so it's definitely one of those things
where i
never started because i'm like what's
the point like i can only see
me like wanting to do this in excess
like
right if it's anything like how i do my
comedy and and
like try to film my schedule and stuff
like that like i'm a workaholic i know
that
like you are that's something that's
just something that i need to i
i don't think if i had an unlimited
amount of funds i would still want to
work and do [ __ ] i just want to go
nuts i feel around even on vacation i
start feeling lazy after yeah
what what can i do i should be doing
like i know it's just like i start
getting a little which
i'm trying to get better at you know but
good luck i know it's hard to get that
hustle mentality out of you you're
just yeah um so you said uh some of the
stuff you sent in you said your brother
used to do
some weird torture [ __ ] to you guys
which i didn't even know about
like until you look back at moments in
your childhood and then you're like that
was weird man
that was weird what would he do how old
is he how much older than you he's three
years older okay so he
he's an older brother that like he's
like a god to me like i love
like everything about him i'm like he's
the coolest you know what i mean
and he would do like weird stuff like
where uh
what i remember he handcuffed me and a
friend
to around the toilet around the base of
a toilet bag of it
yeah and he grabbed hairspray and it
matches and started
shooting flame flames at us
while we're around the toilet
and he's laughing maniacally
we're like and we're literally me and my
friend are literally handcuffed
like military-grade handcuffs because we
used to go to gun and knife shows all
the time so i had police handcuffs
so we're literally around this toilet we
can't move we have no
give it's not toy handcuffs it's metal
police handcuffs
and we can't move at all my brother
thinks it's the funniest thing i don't
remember how he out-muscled the two of
us to get us behind this toilet
but he did he was strong enough to get
two of us like
that and he and he would just love doing
weird stuff like that
like he locked one of my friends in a
kennel
like when we were babysitting my friend
like my dog's kennel yeah and his mom
came down
yeah i saw it and she's like christopher
what are you doing in the dog kennel and
my brother's like
he's behaving he's behaving it's like
we're playing we're playing we're
playing dog again
what is that just weird stuff like he
would like he would um
he would i remember one time he out
muscled uh me
and a friend he somehow pulled all our
clothes off and shoved us
outside in the backyard
so we're completely naked little kids
and he grabbed our our family's
home vcr like shoulder cam recording and
he started filming us and
laughing just laughing at us naked and
what do your parents say about this [ __ ]
they didn't i don't think whatever he
was your brother boys will be boys like
that kind of thing
like it never like we were horrible to
each other like like because he would do
stuff like that i would get my revenge
on him
like he'd get his braces tight and i'd
punch him in the mouth you start
bleeding and then
we're mean to each other man seriously
that three days a week
church will [ __ ] you all up man
that's why most people go we gotta get
those demons out somehow
ryan well i
you have something very interesting i
wanna sort of get to because
i believe you brought a journal did you
not bring a journal or you have some
entries from a journal
i brought a journal and uh this is a
first here on honeydew no one's ever
brought a journal to read from
and this is uh this is this is intense
for me because i've never read this
stuff out loud
so have you ever gone back and read it
yeah again you have so you're
you're you know what you're about to
read you've never read it out i made
some
some uh some posters highlighted the low
lights for us in the book
yeah i tried to help you out i wanted to
come prepared you know this is a first
here so
okay good i can't believe someone's
gonna dig into their journal past
and read to us here look holy [ __ ] look
at all the post-its
it says composition jeremiah watkins
august 28
2010 to july 18 2011. this is roughly a
year's journal right here
yeah very nice so uh a little
fact about me when i moved to los
angeles in july of 2009 i started making
daily journal entries and i've kept that
up
till today that's great so i want to put
together like a book or something
together someday but this is
i was looking through this i was like
all right well i'm coming on the
honeydew
second time i want to do something
special for you guys and
very you're the man so here we go here
we go so these are
never before read aloud to anyone but
yourself
these are inner thoughts these are truly
inner thoughts no one else has ever seen
these
even you don't share these with your
wife or any problem
she probably i i think i've i've read a
couple to her out loud just
like because she'll ask me every once in
a while she's like what did you write
that one day
like and i'll be like all right i i'll
pull this out and see
um let's see there's a there's
there's some different stories what do
you want me to start with some of the
sex stuff or
sure let's hear some of the cringe uh
sex stuff
oh this is this one i just have this is
from friday october 15th
of 2010. okay so this is 10 years ago
and and i mean almost to the day
uh well no wait wait friday you said
october 5th so 10 years ago and
how old are you 10 years ago 10 years
ago i would have been
22. all right 22 and you're in la at
this point or not yet in l.a okay so i
moved out to la
at uh at 19. okay so i'd been here just
uh or excuse me at 20 i moved to l.a so
i've been
out here for like a year and a half okay
basically uh this is just i just titled
this entry weird dream
um just to give you a sense of like what
i was dreaming about back then and stuff
like that
um it says i slept until 1 10 pm today
i had some weird dreams i had a dream
that i was sucking on kim kardashian's
nipple
and i was playing with her boobs
was also hanging with playboy bunnies
later i was doing stand up i have no
idea how these correlate
and then that was the end of that entry
oh i guess my two favorite things
happened in my dreams
i guess so kim kardashian titties and
stand up
um oh here we go
this is i think this is the first kiss
with my wife
yep here we go
all right so my wife
her name's maya maya picked me up uh
from my place around 9 00 pm we went to
go see the social network at the
arclight
i tried to buy her ticket but she
wouldn't let me our showtime was at 10
50 so we walked down sunset all the way
uh to the 101 then we turned around the
social network was really good
she dropped me back off at the house and
i showed her my porch we kissed
hugged and then she took off then i got
a boner haha
i went in for the first kiss i was
pretty awkward we laughed and then tried
it again
this was one of the few times where the
night ended how i thought slash planned
it to
i kissed maya for the first time on
october 21st 2010
which oddly enough in 2017 of october
21st that's when we ended up getting
married
and wow we didn't even realize that it
fell on that date
anniversary you wouldn't realize that if
you didn't journal it you would never
[ __ ] remember your first kiss was
this day
so then um uh then i said after i kissed
her i said i'm such a nerd
colin asked me my roommate why i was so
happy when i was
preparing ramen afterward i said
just got back from a date no big deal
this may be the jew in me but one of the
most attractive things i saw on maya
tonight was when she wouldn't let me pay
for her
i think this trick's a keeper bro
and then it just goes on i'm watching
the best of snl in 1982 right now
i'm about to go to bed i wonder if i'll
start dating maya
how's that entry and you end up marrying
her and you're about to have a child
together yep
which is i mean come on man
oh this is a good one this is um
it's a halloween show that i did um
and uh so it was halloween of 2010.
the show at the attic sucked anneliese
came with two friends
one which i thought was really cute the
energy was terrible in the crowd
it was only people we knew and it was a
light turnout the microphone stopped
working
intermittently throughout my set and i
had to set it down and finish my set
by just projecting i dress as a baby and
only
wore a diaper and bonnet you've got
balls jeremiah said john henry
afterward i drove omar myself to a
halloween house party which easily had
100 or more people
i stayed in the diaper and bonnet and
had a blast
it was cracking people up and pissing
off some
i was dancing with a hot girl and i
started to get a boner in my diaper
oh boners and diapers don't go together
i'll bet
i i got to sleep by about three three
a.m
after i fed the cats there you go
that was that entry do you have an entry
in there about any
um embarrassing moments
or or what about your you mentioned
something about your wife's ring is that
in there
not in this one not that one not in this
one i can tell you about that and we can
hop back into this
i want to hear about the ring because i
want to hear more of these yeah yeah
we'll get back to this in a second
um so
so i told you uh one of the things i
told you before we we started the show
was um
when i proposed to my wife
uh no money whatsoever
how'd you do it so how i did it was
basically
um i had called and talked to her like
her dad ahead of time and stuff like
that but before that
even before i'd called and talked to him
like weeks before like because it had
been
in the talks of our conversation like
what are we like where are we going like
that whole thing
her dad texted me out of the blue and
he's like you have permission to marry
my daughter
i got that text out of the blue before
you even
told him anything yeah as i had you met
him
yeah yeah okay all right all right but
like as i was walking
on stage at a stand-up show i was about
to hit record on
my phone and then the text comes in you
have permission to marry my daughter and
i was like
what like right so i that's all i talked
about that night
like on stage i was like my girlfriend's
dad just texted me i didn't ask him
i didn't ask him to this is so weird and
uh
i got to a place where i was like no
this is like
i'm gonna do it eventually like if if
she's wanting this to happen like right
now like
let's make this happen sooner rather
than later like because i want to do it
eventually but
it just wasn't on my timeline quite yet
so
how i ended up doing it is i uh took her
to the comedy store
uh in the main room i didn't have many
sets in the main room because that's
it's a harder room to perform in uh
typically
and uh that is where she first saw me
like when i like like before we went on
that date to go see that movie like she
saw me have like a killer set that night
and that like that's how you met
she saw you at the comedy you were doing
improv at second city okay
and basically i was like i have a
stand-up show you should come tonight
it's gonna be really fun
and then i did have a killer set and
then like a couple days later i was like
hey you want to hang out
like i was still riding that momentum
like you just saw me
kill like you wanna you wanna go on a
date yeah
let's go uh so i took her to a show
there and then
i took her back to the porch where we
had our first kiss and that's where i
proposed her it was okay
was the was the spot where we had how
long were you dating when you proposed
after you proposed uh we had been dating
already
for uh like six years
oh five six years okay like somewhere
around there yeah
uh so this engagement ring that i got
i've been there bro uh this is another
thing that i've uh haven't talked about
uh this thing was real cheap
like i got it out of marshalls
you bought your wife an engagement ring
of marshalls
you getting engaged ringing some night
pants
maybe they don't maybe they're just
rings you're like nah this one's not
just a rig
wait till i get down on bended knee and
bless this [ __ ] ring
yeah i remember the guy you talk about
glow up
going from a marshalls to a [ __ ]
ladies ring finger forever [ __ ]
it was out in west la by the airport by
lax
and i was so embarra because people
could ask you they are always asking
where'd you get your engagement ring
from
and usually there's a story behind it
and i'm i just kept telling people like
i found this like boutique jeweler out
on the west side and uh
it was the right ring and you know like
i figured i'd get it
and the guy who was checking it out like
when i was getting the ring
he's like oh so what's this for i was
like oh
i'm gonna propose to my girlfriend he
goes
really he's like this [ __ ]
like this one and i was like yeah yeah
yeah
and he's like he's trying to be as nice
as possible but i could see the
disappointment like
this this guy is getting this like this
is his engagement ring
so he was so nice and gave me their
nicest box
the nice he gave me the nicest box on
the outside
this thing is like amazing and then you
pop it open
what's it look like but real quick had
you and your wife i mean you've been
together six years so had she told you
what sort of style she liked that she
talked about anything or were you just
going out in the dark and grabbing this
thing
she said that the ring didn't matter to
her
and i go hey we're going to test don't
matter to me either we're going to test
that theory it mattered more to the guy
selling it i know he's like are you sure
you want to i mean
this is a big deal
uh here's the thing i hope your marriage
lasts forever i don't know if this ring
is going to
you know what i mean i don't know how
diamond this is
diamond yeah exactly so yeah the ring
was
uh one of those things where like it was
very glittery
one of those glitter like very glittery
eye catchy you know i had those
sprinkles all over it right
and my wife had been wanting us to get
married like
the day that we that i was planning on
proposing to her
she's like let's stop off at a pawn shop
or something
and i was like i don't want to stop off
at a pawn shop and she's like no no
i think it'll be fun and like we pulled
over to a pawn shop and she starts
trying on
pawn shop rings in front of me and she's
like telling me her size and stuff and
i'm just
and meanwhile i have the ring on you on
me
in my jacket i'm like cool cool i'm just
like i'm gonna go look at these beat up
saxophones over here cool
go have fun how much were the rings she
was looking at in the pawn shop
probably like at least 500
which is still nothing how much did you
pay
for your engagement i never said this
out loud
i don't know if i can say how much did
you pay for your engagement ring at
marshalls bro
can i guess can i guess because it is
marshalls
i want to go with 68.50 that's what i'm
saying
no it was like after tax they had a
they always had those 30 discount sales
no idea marshalls marshalls is always
marshall's always has a sales
year-round they have 30 sales off round
doesn't matter
what day you go on oh my god uh i think
i
i think it ended up being like like 130.
hey listen it's double the price i
thought
oh god damn
listen i'm gonna tell you what i [ __ ]
up
and i once you buy one by the way
if that [ __ ] doesn't work out you take a
hit like a [ __ ]
an engaging ring so in all honesty
if you're unsure if you're unsure out
there i'm thinking marshalls might be
the way to [ __ ] go bro
you know what i mean they hooked it up
god damn that is hilarious
so get this so my wife is so sweet the
box was 12.
the box was i know it's just alone a
genuine pleather on that box
that's why ring's gone the box
so my wife is such a sweet person that
she was just
excited that we're getting married that
she hid from me
that the ring was so cheap that it was
falling apart
oh man for a long time
there were the the diamonds kept the
stones kept falling out
i can't believe what i'm hearing right
now this is not this is blasphemous how
long
after your initial purchase is this
still under marshall's warranty
dude this is under 90 days bro
had you told her where you got it no i
told her that i got it from a jeweler
it was a jeweler boutique jeweler on the
wall on the west side
and uh she hid that from me because she
didn't want to hurt my feelings because
we didn't have money still don't really
have much money but it's one of those
things where
she's being kind by not telling me she's
going to see somebody else but then i
found out
that she had been going to get it
repaired and i was like
how much did you spend and she was
spending more on
getting it repaired than what was the
value but the [ __ ] jeweler's not
telling her this shit's this is he's a
garbage
he's like she goes um so one of the
stones that the diamond
has fallen out he goes you mean these
metal scraps
because yeah i put it in for free yeah
she went multiple times and a couple of
times she's just like ah just these are
just shavings of diamonds these are
worth nothing
yeah and she never said that to you no
no
i'd be like hey i think you might have
got ripped off or anything like that
like i'm worried you were took
she knew how cheap that thing was but
like she showed like one time i i was
like you know i was looking at her hand
i was like there's like
i was like there's stones missing she's
like ah yeah
they've been kind of falling out for a
little bit i was like what
like we gotta fix this and then
eventually i got her a nicer ring like
she doesn't still have
the marshall's ring when did you finally
have to come to uh
confess uh confess that you got it at
marshalls
she still doesn't know that i got a
marshalls
we should wait to release this out until
the baby's uh delivered bro
we should you should wait she thinks
that i got it like a kohl's or something
like that
slightly way better way better slightly
closer they do have a jewelry department
they do goals
but i got some good khakis while i was
at marshall's too goddamn dude i can't
believe it
i'm so like sickler told me before the
episode he goes
man it's pretty cold in here like are
you all right i'm like dude i'm about to
be getting
so hot telling these stories like that
like they see is fine where it's at like
i'm i'm
sweating so much right now because it's
so cringy and embarrassing
it's so good dude um
all right let's jump back give me a
couple of these journal reviews here
let's see
i mean journal entries yeah yeah
all right this one is
oh we might save that one that's pretty
sad
well that's what we're here for bro i
mean
give me the give me do you have little
titles on them yeah let me pick
read me some titles and let me choose
all right this one says candace
that's it okay that's the sad one
all right do i know that candace okay
so before i
i guess i get into this um because this
is a hard one
when i moved to los angeles i didn't
know uh
anybody and uh i had a friend that
really
took me in like under her wing and uh
she would like cook for me
and we became really good friends we
became uh really close friends and and
she basically uh
was my best friend for like the first
like a year and a half that i lived out
in los
angeles and uh she ended up taking her
life
um around the time that she was 25 it
was like her
25th birthday um and what did she
struggle with
i think she just struggled uh with
depression and stuff like that uh she
ended up uh hanging
herself oh um how'd you find out
uh so i was really close friends with
her
her boyfriend who's still a close friend
of mine sorry
all right yeah yeah that's a little bit
tough all right
please take a minute
so this girl took you in how'd you meet
her
did not expect this
i met her doing uh that's the first job
that i worked in uh
in l.a and not like yeah what'd you do
for your first job here
i i sold uh uh
artist promotional packages to uh
uh to to to musicians which ended up
being a scam later so i had to leave the
job
no you didn't know it was a scam when
you you're selling people
bogus [ __ ] yeah yeah and this is how you
met candace
yeah she was she was like a great sales
person at this job
and uh i was horrible because
i just wanted to uh to hang out and like
riff with people and stuff like that
and uh basically uh
she would cook for me and she was like a
sister basically
and i'm sorry man no please don't be do
you want to take a break ah
no i might just get some tissues here a
second but i'm good
so she was so she was just awesome day
she she really looked after me and stuff
and she would uh
every saturday night i'd go over there
to uh to hang out with her and her
boyfriend
and uh
she was just a good friend she was
somebody who looked out for me who
my mom was like it comforted her that
had somebody sure her son's so far away
from home she's got this good person
he's got this good person looking after
him yeah yeah so um
that was that was one of the things that
that kind of hit me a little bit hard
about brody
was yeah the way he he uh that he went
because uh
man off sort man don't be sorry
because uh it was so similar like the
way that he was found and stuff like
that
no take your time thank you thank you
ash
we'll put ad in here we'll put a hand in
it we'll take a break
we'll be right back after this crisis
real quick
we'll leave you crying drop it out and
come back you're still crying you
haven't even gathered yourself yet
okay snot run right there jeremiah
listen take a quick break tell you about
our next sponsor upstart
you're listening to the honeydew y'all
ryan
i hope you enjoyed yourself right now
i don't know why i turned this into a
therapy session but i did
i was just talking about i was just
talking up a second ago
about getting boners and diapers and
then and then it went
went south real quick i'm so sorry
gather yourself please
we'll get back to it in a second here
hey hey everybody get your night pants
right now
there's tissue on the table and [ __ ]
oh god
jeremiah wonders t-shirts jeremiah
watkins.com they work really good
is that for me that's for you bro that's
your shirt
with real tears those real tears real
tears jeremiah wonders great podcast
i had so much fun on it this is this is
this is the dumbest i can't believe this
is
this this as comedians how we try to
deal with
with deep trauma that hasn't been talked
about forever oh
[ __ ] so she was an amazing friend
who just like i felt comfortable in la
my family felt good
about me having somebody who was had my
best interest at heart who had my back
and um i became really close with her
and her boyfriend
and uh
i think the tipping point for her was uh
her 25th birthday
uh she was trying to get people to just
come out
and like a bunch of people ghosted her
and like
just didn't come and just were flaky you
know what i mean
and like she obviously was dealing with
a lot of depression stuff like that and
this
put that over the top oh man and uh
my brother was visiting at the time and
my mom's like you don't need to go to
her party tonight your brother's in town
visiting nelly how often is your brother
in town and i was like no i have to go
to this party like
like i gotta be there for candace and
like i i went and i like i was
i was like one of the only friends that
showed up
and uh her last facebook status was like
just her she's like [ __ ] man
she's like i just she's like i just need
ah like like i just need a girls night
like i just need like
uh a couple friends uh like
is anybody like available like anybody
and like everybody just like
literally comments on this facebook
thread like sorry like i wish i could
see you like like people like
just like putting it off kind of thing
like i don't think anybody like actually
like
reached out like actually just was there
for her
and uh uh i
i'll read what i have written i guess
yeah
you sure yeah get the kleenex bro i know
i know
this will be good keep them up on this
you can keep them up on the table all
right let's
just keep them on deck i don't know who
you think you're fooling i know i know
i'm not as strong as i'd like to think i
am
oh
well i will say this i have to say this
woman must have meant the world to you
because
my god here jeez
let me throw those kleenex on the floor
just knock yeah just
let's sanitize the table when we're done
my nose is so big like all the
clinicians
we had to burn the studio we had to get
a blanket over here he used the carpet
okay all right
one of my best friends candace passed
away today
my friend called me after improv
practice at sunset grill
and told me they can't just hung herself
and was dead i was in disbelief
i got to their apartment as fast as i
could the police and coroner
was there when i arrived as soon as i
saw my friend i broke down and started
bawling
how could this have happened she was she
was such a good person she was
a very emotional person but i never
thought that anything like this would
ever happen
on saturday she was upset because not
enough people came to her birthday party
uh her boyfriend uh kept telling me
how much she was loved and and he said
she really loved you jeremiah you're a
good friend
at 10 30 i did uh the valuement you show
at ios in the delco's theater which is a
is an improv group that i was a part of
at the time
it was a pretty good show peter asked me
what
i was holding back after the show and i
broke down again
i try to keep it together but i couldn't
i talked to billy
uh around until about 12 20 a.m he gave
his condolences
i loved candace so much she was like a
sister me i i can't believe she's gone
i'm emotionally drained right now aunt
cindy's death hit me hard tonight too
i pray that god helps my friend
my friend and i through this time
um so within the first like year and a
half
of uh can i say something real quick
yeah yeah
the the wherewithal
and the strength and the power to put
pen to paper during a time like that
is pretty impressive not just the
process not just to think and talk but
also to write something down
i wish i would have gone back and done
that when i was 16 years old
i wish i could have should have
wrote something down to go back and look
on that because also
these are great to look at where you
were where you are now
and the people that helped influence
that and and were a part of that
um so what were
what was it like after that i mean it
was just
it was just hard because um i think one
of the reasons why i wanted to
force myself to to share this today was
uh
suicide is just one of those things that
like i don't think that the people who
you know they're obviously not thinking
it through
what when they happen they don't realize
the pain and anguish that they're gonna
the there that the people have to live
with after they're gone and
how much people care about them i'm
still thinking about
you you're late on a minute what what
year was this again 21
this is like 20 you say 10 11 10 yeah
20 10 20. yeah 2010 decade ago yeah
so it's like you know what i mean like
like it's just one of those things where
like if this can help anybody like
like realize that they're loved and that
you know like this is what it does
to people but like then i'm happy to
share
this hurtful story you know
uh do you want to get to a little more
lighthearted uh
horrible [ __ ] and tell me about the you
want to do that real quick before i
tiptoe your last story
yeah yeah yeah basically i'm trying
moving you away from the sadness
yeah yeah we've got a tissue budget here
at the dude jeremiah you've already
i know i've already i've already done it
so
so basically when you're grieving
the thing that's hard about it and what
happened in the first year and a half
that i that i uh
moved to la i lost uh an aunt that i
really loved i lost candace and i lost
uh my big pop my grandpa on
my mom's side so that kind of all like
you know those stack
like yeah when that happens so it also
to me at least
when i would lose a relative back home
it felt it felt like i was on the other
side of the world
you know what i mean so far away and
removed where i couldn't get there in
time and all that stuff it always felt
weird to have someone pass when i wasn't
there
this was hard and i i literally had a
talk with um
my uncle literally last year i didn't go
back
for my aunt's funeral and i told him
that i regretted it like
for a decade almost and we both
like cried about it and he and he's like
i never
like held that against you or anything
but that's very nice of you that you
you know so thank her like that um which
that was a good
cathartic moment for us both is us like
just like realizing like hey i was a kid
when like i don't like funerals are not
meant sometimes for you you're supposed
to be there for the other people
even if you're not a funeral person like
and i'm not like i would rather
celebrate somebody's life than go to a
funeral
other people need you there and they
will sometimes hold that against you
down the road not that my uncle did but
just that's something a life lesson that
i learned
like kind of a different way let's get
into some more light
thursday january 20th 2011 i trimmed my
pubes for the first time in my life
how old were you again 22. i was in my
20s bro
all right yeah my penis felt weird all
day
and my superman underwear did not
support me at all
that's [ __ ] you gotta shave nick
behind superman underwear
oh dude well i'll tell you what
put the journal down i don't want to
take you through any more of that
and tell me about this go ahead if you
have one more but i'm dying to hear
about this dave chappelle story
okay yeah that's probably how we'll
close you
uh i'll do one more quick one um this
one this one says uh
oh i can't believe i wrote this this is
so weird
yup this is very bizarre um
i'm talking about my wife now
i said uh i was we were doing some
writing for a sketch
and we didn't get very far we started
making out on my bed and that was pretty
cool
we talked about our relationship and the
label of boyfriend girlfriend
uh
i can't even read right anyway
we were kissing for a while and she said
do you want to make out with
our shirts off
our shirts off are you guys the same age
by the way roughly okay
before i knew it i said sure it had my
shirt off
i thought she was gonna keep her bra on
but no
i was pleasantly surprised i sucked on
my first boobies today
other than my mom's when i was a baby
that was the first time you'd ever suck
little girls
my god
we rolled around made out and felt out
each other up for quite a while
we were in bed for almost a couple hours
mama called me after 6 p.m which was
8-ish her time
she was asking me why i hadn't called
her i told her i was hanging with maya
and she knew something was up i said
i'll call you tomorrow as i was grinning
ear to ear
and then that's the end of that
well glad that turned out good for you
now now your baby is about to start
sucking on your wife's
how about that we'll get we'll get to
these uh another time there's
he'll be back bro yeah yeah you'll be
back with that book
i've got a stack of these i bet every
decade that's a deck
that's a year right how many years
you've been doing this yeah i've been
doing
it the last 11 years man
how are you not doing that podcast i
don't know jeremiah
you but give it to people to read
because it's obviously really easy for
me to freaking do
i mean i would have people sit and read
your entries to you and like what the
[ __ ] going on here oh that's
you were you were 22 and you sucked on
your first titties but yeah man and talk
about that
took a minute um
okay so this story uh
a lot of highs and uh that ends with a
low
that's that's the show bro that's a show
um so i this just happened a few weeks
ago i was out in new york
uh promoting my special and people were
kind enough to have me on their podcast
and stuff out there in
the new york scene and i was doing spots
and stuff like that so i'm doing
a rooftop show um
through like uh stamp new york or one of
the clubs
and uh the host on the show is like hey
i heard that um
dave chappelle is having a secret
snl after party uh tonight at the stand
i go oh because he was running his
monologues and stuff there right
originally
yeah he was hosting um uh and he was
hosting snl that weekend
and um so
i go really um that's cool i have a spot
there
a little bit later tonight so maybe i'll
talk to the manager and see
what's up so i talked to the manager and
he's like yeah it's happening for sure
he's like i'll
do my best to get you in but uh
we'll see i mean it's this after party
so i can't make any guarantees i'm like
cool
i'm like what time should i come back
and he's like come back at like 1 30.
because by the time they're wrapped with
snl and everything you know
takes a while for the after party even
get started
so i got to the bronx i'm playing sax
out on this uh
this buddy's gig um out there so i have
my sax with me
and i roll back into the city around
1 30 in the morning take an uber from
the bronx all the way back to manhattan
and uh i go to the door uh sacks my hand
and uh there's a guy with a clipboard
and uh he goes
yeah what's up i was like hey
dave's having his uh this thing here uh
i'm just gonna head in he's like uh
what's your name like
jeremiah watkins and he goes nope
and i go okay okay go go go i was like
i'm gonna text some people he goes you
do that i was like
all right so i go randomly uh
i know dave's manager because i used to
play basketball with him
like 11 years ago and we stayed in touch
and he's nice enough to
respond to my text messages still and so
i texted him and i texted the manager of
the club and i was like hey i'm outside
uh
stand right now i'd love to you know
come in
he's like how many people in your party
where already over capacity he like he
got back to me right away
he's i i don't know but i'll do my best
mandrake got back to me immediately he
goes
show this text to the door guy i'm going
to get you in i was like
okay great go up to the door guy again
and i was like
ah here you go and the guy
looks at it and then he looks at me he's
like all right head on in
he goes but go to that back room
immediately i go okay okay
they're doing rapid cover testing so
people can
either stay at the party or bounce you
know so
i'm getting this uh test done i see like
some different comics there like joe
derosa by the way i'm gonna preface this
there's gonna be
name dropping in this story just because
of for the story for the story
for what it is okay different comics i
see joe derosa and some different people
uh
that are already there and i'm like kind
of saying what's up i'm like yeah i
gotta go
get my test and it's just exciting that
like you're seeing other people that are
also
inside you're like oh this this is cool
like is this about to happen
i go to get my kova test and uh the lady
like has me fill out paperwork and stuff
like that and then
without telling me she just shoves the
thing up my nose i'm like you want me to
sit down or
anything like this and like she's like
no you're fine just like doing that just
like you know doing the whole thing
my you know a big nose like she's like
climbing a spiral staircase to get to
the top
she's shimming like a chimney sweep up
there
the whole thing and uh i have to wait 10
or 15 minutes before
i know if i have covert or not and
during those 10 or 15 minutes i have so
much anxiety bro because this
the next week like i'm planning a move
with my wife
back in la so if like if i have covet
i have to quarantine in new york for two
weeks
that'll cost a crazy amount of money and
then also i'm the la comedian
that brought covet i interacted with
probably 50 comedians that week doing
their podcasts and doing gigs and i went
to philly that week and like i was in
cars with like big j and dan soder all
those guys
and i'm i'm stressed i'm like this is
going to be
the worst thing ever if i can't and then
luckily she comes over to me
puts a bracelet on me so he goes okay
you're good to go head over there see
security
talk to security um he you know puts one
of those magnet things on my phone so
you can't be texting or taking photos or
videos or anything he's like all right
man have fun head on down
head down into the basement of the stand
and uh
basically i start seeing more comics
more new york comics uh that i know and
stuff like that and on stage there's two
djs
um and uh one dj i don't know but one
the other dj i do know is cypher sounds
he's great dj works with chappelle a lot
and i was like what's up man we worked
together on the impractical jokers
cruise and i just
started chopping up with him a little
bit and uh i was like yeah man i brought
my sax just in case tonight he goes oh
for real he's like
we might use that okay cool i was like
all right so i put in the back i'm like
that's kind of crazy let's see like
derek gaines and like dulce sloan some
different new york comics and stuff
they're starting to hang out
and we're all hanging out and and
basically a waitress comes around you
can get whatever you want and
i was like sweet like they're like yeah
it's on dave like get whatever you want
so i got a pizza and a coke and i was
like this is amazing
so dulcinea split a piece and stuff and
we're just waiting for the
the after party kind of start because
the celebrities and different people
hadn't
been there yet from the show because
they're literally just getting off stage
and leaving 30 rock and stuff like that
so the energy changes all of a sudden in
the room
because dave spell walks in the room man
of the hour
and everybody starts cheering for him he
just killed it on saturday night live
and it's just like this cool moment and
uh
he takes the stage and starts talking on
the mic and
he's he says a very cool like welcoming
speech to everybody he goes
if you're in this room tonight you're
meant to be
here so don't treat tonight like some
lottery ticket
or something like that you're wanted
here so be comfortable
we went out of our way to make sure
everybody's safe and tested
and negative nobody has coveted so just
enjoy yourself tonight
and have fun and i was like that's all
you needed to hear
that's all i needed to hear is
i'm a part of this you know what i mean
i'm
be here i was like he wants to hell just
told me
that he wants me here so
we're dancing around and and stuff like
every all the comics and stuff like
uh cyphers like hidden like dope hip hop
and like dave is kind of emceeing a
party he's just like the
the conductor of this party like the
vibes and stuff like that
and the energy changes again in the room
because everybody's head
turned and in walks
chris rock with jim carrey come on
jesus christ and chappelle goes give it
up
for chris rock and jim carrey they join
him on stage
of the stand and everybody's just in awe
because
these three titans of comedy are on the
mic
together they're just riffing and
they're just like
still in ecstasy from a great snl and
that day was the day that biden got
elected
and those guys are all yeah supporters
of biden
so they were extra excited and
uh and carrie's doing them now and
carrie's
literally doing bikes on saturday night
live he is joe biden
cipher sounds hits nipsey hustles
and ygs [ __ ] donald trump and chris rock
jim carrey and dave chappelle
all started screaming [ __ ] donald trump
the whole stand
is chiming in it's like a back and forth
and i'm jumping up and down just
literally i'm laughing i'm just laughing
at how ridiculous
what is happening around me you know
what i mean and out of nowhere
the energy changes again because andrew
yang the presidential candidate
pops up on stage and he goes let's give
it up for
joe biden no yes
joe biden was there no no
i was like what this [ __ ] rolled
in
here
and uh then he disappears out of nowhere
and then the energy shifts again it
keeps on getting higher and bumped up
higher and higher
because chappelle then goes ladies and
gentlemen
give it up for dave grohl come on dave
grohl from foo fighters
walks in and joins them on stage now
it's dave grohl
chappelle jim carrey and chris rock all
standing next to each other
like chumming it up just like riffing
and stuff having a good time
and they drop there goes my hero by the
foo fighters come on
and they played it so loud it blew the
speakers in the stand
and quickly they had that like like and
then chappelle's like trying to talk on
the mic he's like
river is like oh man this mic is [ __ ]
up all right
so the djs quickly spin their monitors
around that they had for them and then
they use it as speakers for the house
they literally had this party still
going within
90 seconds it was crazy they're
professionals that's what they do
so the vibe is going strong and
everything like that and i'm just like
looking around i'm like
man this is awesome this is great like
and i see
i keep finding myself looking at jim
carrey
because he's my idol he's like my number
one favorite comedian
if if you like classify that it's always
like jim carrey steve martin and chris
farley are my guys when people ask me
and the first time that i was supposed
to meet jim carrey
was that roast battle at the comedy
store the show that i was part of every
week
yup he came to the comedy store after
not being there for like 20 years
and judged rose battle and i was not
there
why when did you ever miss a roast
battle exactly
i took a weak gig in reno to pay my
bills
so my phone is blowing up in the middle
of the night like i went to go pee
and i check my phone like kind of tired
and then like
i saw on my phone like where were you
tonight you missed jim carrey
and i like looking at my phone i go on
facebook i go on instagram
it's littered with people taking
pictures with jim carrey and stuff
and i looked at those photos and i cried
myself to sleep
i could understand it's this part of the
show that i'm on
everywhere everywhere and i'm physical
on that show i get to be silly and zany
goof i'm like
you'd have been able to play with him i
know i would have i would have been
trying to riff with him the whole thing
it was crushing to me
that was the first time i was supposed
to meet him
second time i held back
was at mitzi shore's funeral smart smart
the whole back there
yeah i was like i can't do this i can't
be the guy that goes up to jim carrey
like when he's mourning somebody who he
just lost and be like i'm a big fan
man i passed i saw him i was like that's
good enough for me
i said he's in the building at the
comedy store this is a special moment
i'll hold on
to that thing i did
so i'm looking around i see him talking
to punky johnson
our friend newest cast member on snl
and he uh is talking with punky on stage
at the stand and i'm just like
this is so cool i'm gonna walk over like
even if i don't talk like i just want to
remember what he's saying to punky and
like a couple
of uh other people who worked at the
comics over there like bianca and lee
and i'm talking with them a little bit
but also kind of like
keeping focus on day on on what jim
is saying to punky and uh punky's like i
love you jim and
and he's like i said i love you you're
doing so great on the show like keep up
the great work like he's just
being so nice to her and encouraging
she's like i go on 15 minutes on how
much i love you and
and and he's like no it's uh that's very
nice you say but i love you keep up the
great work and
they you know they hug and then punky
rolls off and
uh the stage and i was hoping ideally
that the conversation would just
naturally swing to you
roll into me because i'm right there
but have you ever been in like a circle
where you realize like you weren't a
part of
the conversation the entire time and
then you're just left standing there
that's what it was so he goes back to
bopping his head during the music he's
still wearing his mask because he's
there's some people wearing their mask
and inside even though they just got
contested or still
not wanting to take it off he's popping
his head around and then i
i just i'm like jeremiah if you're gonna
talk to him this is this is
literally the closest he's as close as
we are right now
and i'm at the foot of the stage on the
floor and i just
i look up at him and i just
you touch him i touch him where where if
you're looking up and where are you
touching them i do one of these
and he looks down and i'm looking up
and like ah hey hey jim i
um i'm i'm a paid regular with punky at
the comedy store uh
i just wanted to tell you that um i i
just read your recent book that you put
out memoirs and misinformation i really
enjoyed it
guys oh i'm glad you enjoyed it that's
really nice
and and i go and obviously i'm a fan of
everything you do
i love everything you do that's what i
said obviously i love everything you do
because that's very nice he goes what's
your name i go jeremiah
jeremiah watkins he looks and he goes
he like reaches his hand down and this
is covered time so this is a big deal to
me he reached his hand down
and he his hands are probably the same
size as mine but they felt like giant
hands
wrapping around mine shaking my hand he
goes nice to meet you man
he goes well
it took me 15 years of working the clubs
before i started landing anything so all
i can say is
just enjoy the ride i said i'm grateful
for everything
uh absolutely all the time i'm grateful
for everything thank you
and that was that was all i knew that
that was all that i needed like i
i bowed out after that i was like i'm
not going to try it out yank his ear or
anything he's like i said what i needed
to
kind of thing but now i'm feeling real
good
i'm on another level now
i can't wait i just met jim carrey my
idol
who can i talk to now i'm looking at
flights to try to postpone
to not go home because it's already
past three in the morning it's like 3 30
my flight's at 6 30.
and it takes a while to get out to jfk
as you know from in the city
i'm trying to plan no flights are
available i also don't want to call my
wife and be like i miss my flight
because i was i stayed but she she would
be cool whatever she'd understand
but no flights available like till the
next day i'm like oh i have to go home
so i got to make something happen and uh
i go up to the dj and i go
man this song's making me want to play
sax
and he goes oh yeah go grab it i go
what he goes go grab your sax let's do
it i go
uh okay i go to the back
assemble my sacks real quick and i'm in
the back of the room
and this lady sees me with the sacks she
goes are you about to go on stage with
them
because dave is still conducting he's
being a vibe creator
he's conducting just the feels of this
party it's his parties his after-parties
his private thing
and i go i think like uh yeah i think so
i'm just we'll see
maybe in a second and then punky sees me
and she goes are you about to go up on
stage jay
i was like yeah i'm feeling it i'm like
trying to find the key and stuff the
right pitch and everything
and she goes you got to get your ass up
there okay
so i start playing the sacks as i
you're playing yourself on
but only the dj knows that you've got
the green jay knows that i got the green
light
oh [ __ ] so i start playing myself on
and it gets a great response because
it's a party there's a dude with the sax
that's randomly appearing on the stage
it sounds cool
it's like oh this is great you know and
dave looks over at me and he shoots me a
look
and he sees and he he's he's listening
for like half a second
he goes gives me a knot of approval
i'm like dope so i hang back a little
bit on the stage
and i'm just chiming in a little bit
here and there feeling it out you know
just adding a little licks here and
there
like because it's like different hip hop
and stuff that's being played and
he looks at me uh after a little bit
after i'm playing and he goes
like a little bit less a little bit less
i was like
i got you dave chappelle no problem
so i'm doing a little bit less and the
dj scifi
he leans over he's like he's like put on
these headphones can you play this hook
of this of this horn section i go let me
listen to it real quick
listen to it i'm like okay i got it
so he plays the next song horn section
comes in
i start playing sounds pretty good dave
looks over me again he goes
you got two of them now got two of them
now that was my second warning
i got yeah i got you man yeah
and the dj pulls inside he goes hey man
on this next song i'm about to play kill
me softly this is his favorite song
do not play on any part where there's
vocals
if he's singing don't play sacks i was
like sure
no problem so i started waiting
everybody i'm getting nervous
best vibes everybody's just like living
it
this is dave's favorite song people can
feel that radiating off of him
so i wait for moments where there's not
lyrics
and i'm like like little stuff like that
and dave looks over and he goes the
third and final time
and he goes
it just waved you off like a fly
he shooed me oh [ __ ] and with
under two seconds security from the back
of the room
shoots me a look like come here
and like but he looked at you and did
that dave look you're
directly you're not security like you
look at you
jeremiah you're done you're not
you're done bro
and so i security
off
meanwhile i'm wearing a sax hat too yes
i'm wearing my
merch my jeremiah like i'm all saxophone
out i'm the sax
guy right now and uh i'm bobbing my head
and like i'm grooving to the music and
then i exit off stage slowly as i
kind of dance off and the security goes
hey man um
i think it's time we pack up that sex
tonight he goes and i love seeing you up
there man he goes i'm a sax player
myself but i think
dave's a little over it now i was like
hey i appreciate you being cool and
pulling me aside like this
that's really nice of you and uh yeah uh
i said scifi said it was cool for me to
go up like i wouldn't just
do that without permission so i
appreciate and he's like no absolutely
man have a good night
and i packed up my sacks i left
immediately
he tried to get that flight back
i was trying to get on the flight before
you got hurt
because i didn't want to be remembered
to chappelle as the guy who crashed his
party who like was uninvited and i'm
like
god i hope that pops up in the next
special like there was this one night
god i hope it comes up in the next
special the saks guy
yeah man it was dude that had to feel
awful
dude i literally just went from the
highest high of meeting jim carrey to
being shoes and getting the okay from
getting
all right and then like and then uh yeah
i went to the airport
i found a five dollar bill on the ground
and then boarded the flight and made it
home safe
there it is bro there it is
dude this has been such a really good
episode thank you so much
for coming on here and i mean man you
went for it bro
i tried man you brought a journal which
is the first time anybody's read from a
journal on this show
um i'm sorry for your loss i can tell
that candace meant the world to you and
still does
yeah which is i hope somebody out there
someday when i'm gone talks about me and
feels about me like that
after 10 years i really do because that
woman made an impression on you
obviously
yeah i mean well it just it just goes to
show you that
kindness and love can really go a long
way when when people need it and
uh like i said like it's just an example
like
i'm a grown man who has a pretty good
grip
on my emotions and like i did not expect
that to come i'm like i got this i'll be
able to read about this no problem and
dude it just hit me really hard like
flooding back
good memories and stuff that i had uh
with her as a friend and stuff like that
so
uh if you you know if i don't want to
make a psa or anything but if you're if
you're thinking about
doing something harmful for yourself
like there's people who love you
that want your best interest like don't
do anything like that like
give somebody a call like it's worth
making the effort to give a call because
somebody cares
about you enough to make an effort to
respond so yeah and that's not a psa
that's great advice and it's
it's yeah thank you for sharing it and
as your family used to say
amen amen amen
um please promote everything again your
special all of it
uh my one hour special is on amazon
prime
video on demand apple tv uh if you uh
want to find it you can find it pretty
easily or if you're an audio person my
album is
uh jeremiah watkins family reunion the
special and the album are streaming on
all platforms right now
and like i said great podcast with ryan
sickler and jeremiah wonders
and jeremiah stand up on all social
media love you brother thank you for
watching
share that and uh and uh you know
have some breakthroughs i guess yeah man
well thank you for sharing and thank you
for being
open enough to come here and do that i
appreciate it you know i love you hit me
up
um as always ryan sickler on all social
media
ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week